[Música]
obra de arte de la arquitectura clásica
el castillo volví con es el hermano
mayor de versalles el que le sirvió de
modelo un monumento que encierra entre
estos muros tres siglos y medio de
historia
una responsabilidad que recae sobre los
hombros de tres hermanos que lo
heredaron en cuanto murió su padre se
trata de ascanio álex hongo y johnson
uno se da cuenta cuando es un poco más
adulto del peso de la responsabilidad
también de la suerte que tenemos de
vivir aquí y ser entre comillas
propietarios depositarios de este
monumento y si uno se imagina todo lo
que debe ser realizado con
responsabilidad frente a la historia
había tres siglos y medio de historia
paraliza un poquito nosotros somos tan
sólo uno de los eslabones de esta enorme
cadena que permanece unida y relaciona
el pasado con el gestión
construido en el siglo 17 bajo el
impulso de nicola fu que el castillo
reúne los talentos del arquitecto lobo
del jardinero lo notó y del pintor lewin
halloween quien desde su apartamento
tenía acceso directo al domo del
castillo
los andamios estaban instalados en
hebrón tenía acceso desde la ventana de
su habitación entonces desde aquí subía
al andamio lo que le evitaba asumir 12
metros desde el suelo y
desafortunadamente el arresto del porque
de septiembre de 1961 le puso fin a la
obra y por lo tanto la pintura no puede
ser realizada
fu que el amigo de las artes gran
mecenas del reino amaba demasiado el
lujo y terminó haciendo enfadar a su rey
luis 14 quien lo hizo detener
se podría en prisión hasta el final de
sus días el rey sol se inspira de su
castillo para construir versalles volví
con será entonces olvidado y saldrá del
anonimato en 1968 con su apertura al
público para financiar su restauración
desde entonces todas las ideas son
buenas para encontrar recursos tal como
hacer adoptar estatuas
esta estatua del siglo 17 es una esfinge
que cuida la vivienda estaba cubierta de
liquen los rasgos de su rostro empezaban
a desaparecer entonces había cierta
urgencia logramos financiar estas 62
estatuas en menos de dos años porque la
gente quiere creo pertenecer un poco a
la historia apropiarse un poco de
historia
en vuelo vi con las obras se encadenan
las rejas de las puertas centrales
necesitan un poco de renovación
una restauración que debe hacerse de
manera idéntica es decir a mano según
las técnicas de la época esta delicada
operación tiene lugar en esta herrería
de lyon
las rejas costado sur estaban en su
lugar desde hace 350 años
hay mucho óxido esta reja ha sufrido
mucho en algunos lugares aquí faltan
elementos aquí sólo está la mitad y lo
vamos a hacer de nuevo este lo vamos a
rechazar este se ve bien el hierro
forjado en el siglo 17 fue carcomido por
los elementos los rosetones los quitamos
para verificar que no tengan rotos de
cualquier forma los vamos a cambiar
todos pero primero tienen mucho trabajo
para arreglar todos estos espirales la
reja estando un elemento de seguridad
como de prestigio el testigo de la
grandeza del castillo y de la potencia
de su propietario
cada año al final de la primavera el
castillo se sumerge de nuevo en 1661 en
la época del rey sol los comensales
repiten la famosa fiesta en la que
nicolás fo que puso celoso a luis 14
emulando con un concurso que promete
regalos por parte del castillo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
john sayles el árbitro de las elegancia
acompañado por su familia incita a los
visitantes a inscribirse a la
competencia una boleta para participar
en el concurso del picnic más bello se
asocia un poco todo a la vez costumbres
colores del mantel que van con los
colores de los platos un poco de
búsqueda en los platos a cosas todo el
trabajo un poco con ello realizado para
hacer algo elegante
[Música]
me gusta
los terciopelos las plumas y otros
encajes se apresuran a participar es tan
bellas están muy bellas lindo vestido
número 2 tomaré una foto
soy un soldado romano
algunas personas me han dicho que es un
momento excepcional para ellas porque
les gusta revivir este periodo y si
pudiesen vivir en aquella época lo
harían no es nuestra voluntad por
supuesto pero nuestra voluntad es darle
vida a este lugar
[Música]
sueños de princesa amor por los
disfraces o nostalgia por los tiempos
antiguos cada uno vive la experiencia a
su manera
para los propietarios esta fiesta es un
evento que confirma cada año la
notoriedad del lugar dando vida a la
historia de este castillo de vanguardia
[Música]
[Aplausos]